Oh Oswald he just he's never learned
[Applause]
[Music]
Gotham this video going up a little bit
later in the day than was originally
planned but it I am recovering from a
bit of an insane weekend inside in a
good way it was at the Vermont burlesque
Festival but yeah that was that was long
and then had to drive back in immense
snowstorm and deal with us no once I got
back so yeah running a little behind but
still gotta go out on the same day as
originally planned in any case we are up
to episode 3 of season 5 the final
season of Gotham so what have we got
here well I mentioned him at the top why
don't we start with Oswald now initially
I was kind of a little bit and like I've
talked about this before that I've been
kind of irritated with the pattern of
what they've done with Oswald which is
that he caused his way to the top he
tumbles back down causes the way to the
top tumbles back down top-down top-down
and that was starting to annoy me and it
was beginning to hear in this season as
well but for some reason something
clicked in my head
that didn't fully click before and
that's not to say that they didn't bring
it across just for some reason I didn't
connect the dots
Oswald's problem he sees a conqueror not
a ruler he doesn't know how to change
tactics once his ruthlessness has gotten
him into a position of power he doesn't
understand that you have to then shift
gears into another mode of being in
order to maintain that power if you try
and rule the same way you conquered well
exactly what happened here is what's
gonna happen which is that they're your
people are gonna revolt and no one's
gonna back you and I don't I think maybe
the reason it didn't click for me before
was because I don't at least I don't
remember the sort of mass exodus of the
people who are supposed at least
courting him happening before like it
had been you know here and there you
know issues with Butch things like that
but I think having it happen on mass
like this really and and it not be a
case of like oh well they were offered
better you know whatever from another
gang boss you know a better cut or
what-have-you but having it people who
are already desperate you know and going
into a situation that is only maybe
slightly better than the one he's
offering and that he's gonna be very
ticked at them for but they do it anyway
really kind of finely hammered at home
like oh you you just uh you just don't
know how to be at the top do you you
know how to get there you don't know how
to be there um we got a few more little
bits with the dog particular weight
liked I did also like that
Oswald seemed genuinely torn up as sort
of his his main guy getting killed even
after that guy had abandoned him I
thought that was a that was a nice touch
because as much as Oswald doesn't value
people generally if he's gonna lose them
he wants it to be on his terms and at
his call and when it happened when he
wasn't prepared to he gets upset
including in slightly emote more
emotional ways than you would call from
him so that was pretty cool what's going
out with Selina is actually working for
me pretty well I need I am unless
something happens that forces me to
accept it I'm kind of gone ahead Canon
it that the thing that IV gave Bruce
just healed her and didn't do anything
about change your personality or
bringing out her darkness because I feel
like everything she's doing is totally
viable just on the basis of look trying
to be nice got me paralyzed and almost
killed screw that so I like that's my
head Canon right now and watching her
unleash watching you basically say to
heck with your rules Bruce they don't
help and watch her go down this darker
path I think is working well and didn't
need that stupid justification so that's
and that's my head Canon unless
something happens in the show that
forces me to not be able to thread that
needle but she's working pretty well for
they're doing an interesting job of
building up Jeremiah because this is now
three episodes in he had his debut last
season he was a beef he and his actions
are a big part of why we're even the
situation yet he is so far not present
and it's doing a decent job of making me
want to see him which is actually fairly
impressive because I'm not a huge fan of
Jeremiah I like Jerome much much better
but the way that they're teasing his
return is making me more excited for
when that happens so there's a tactic
that's working that's cool
so we've now got with with the character
EKKO who has appeared before but she is
now being positioned pretty firmly as a
Harley Quinn analog which disappoints me
slightly because if we were gonna go for
a full-on Harley Quinn analog I really
would have liked Laurie Petty's
character from season two to come back
like I like Lori petti anyway I really
did love that character and I think
that's still my favorite episode of the
show the one she was in but setting that
aside sort of my own personal preference
of oh it's not what I wish it was and
sort of taking it on board for what it
is
yeah pretty interesting I like that at
least the vibe that I get off her is
there is that obsession with Jeremiah
there is obviously that ruthlessness and
that craziness but at least has
presented he or she feels like she has a
fair amount of agency which is why I
prefer for Harley one of the things that
really ticked me off about the new 52
version of Harley which is also what
they ended up doing for the Suicide
Squad movie was that she you know she
did fall in love with the Joker and she
did help him but sort of what pushed her
over the edge was him tossing her into a
vat of chemicals like he was and I don't
like like I accept that the Joker drives
her nuts but I still want the choices
she makes to be heard choices so I've
always preferred original origin for
Harley and I'm okay with this one too
because it what it feels like is she
knows
my she kind of worshipped Jeremiah but I
don't get the feeling like he's directly
telling her that what she's doing in
this episode in terms of the sort of
weird Church culty thing with the with
the Russian Roulette and with everything
else like I don't get the feeling that
she's doing this on his instruction I
feel like she's doing this because she
thinks that's the kind of thing he would
like which is again what I like for
Harley like her going to these extremes
and doing these bizarre and awful things
thinking it'll impress somebody who
doesn't and I'm getting that sort of
general vibe while it's still being very
Gotham um I think that's pretty cool um
I was surprised how much I liked that
because I had forgotten cuz I haven't
been keeping up good since I already
knew this was lassies and I hadn't been
keeping up too much with with the
production as it was going on I did I
did
I hear that there was gonna be some kind
of Harley Quinn character in but I'd
forgotten about that and seeing this
play out was actually pretty nice and I
liked it quite a bit I like I was
surprised because even though I kind of
forgotten that it was gonna happen
thinking back on it now I do remember
first here and yeah we'll have a Harley
Quinn kind of character I remember
thingy
do we have to and I part of that might
just be the characters overexposure at
this point because DC slaps are into
everything but that said this is a
pretty decent take and definitely fits
the world 10 that we've got so yeah I'm
digging all this I like this eye this
felt like a better progression of the
overall story and of shifting the
dynamics of the characters then the
previous episode the previous episode
have felt a little bit wheel spinning
this one does not this one feels like
things moving forward die pieces are
moving so that we're actually going to
progress the story I'm not sure how much
of the story actually got moved forward
in this one but what we saw was either
new or was sort of solidifying things
that were hinted at before like with
Selina like we knew she was gonna go
darker how's it gonna manifest oh by
being more violent by taking bigger
risks that's how it's gonna manifest
cool so it's sort of filling in the
details for the stuff that had been kind
of laid out in the last episode or two
and now we're sort of getting into the
nitty-gritty of that and that's working
pretty well for me and then building
explosion at the end yeah that I mean
again that's Gotham for you the things
don't seem exciting enough blow it up
uh-huh so I'll be interested to see you
see next week's have a how that goes so
Gotham episode 3 of season 5 you seen it
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff down there besides
because there's buttons and there's
links and there's merch and there's a
link to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way which would be
awesome um but you know what there's a
links the whole bunch of other stuff
besides that there's my P o box check it
all out or don't check any of it out if
you don't want to because you know what
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]